yeah welcome to this video it's another
five minutes a game here in the auto
pairing against them some player from
the United States boots star there are
so many players that I don't know I
really think I never played the sky very
high rated but he has no idea about this
opening obviously okay so let's not get
too optimistic even if this is some is
already very good for wide what yeah
okay I thought you would play okay yeah
this is one of those games if you do
some you know that you had a bad day
because he's just playing complete crap
and tries to do something on time okay
so 93 just back on a form young
everything's good
okay let's go here prevent a c6 for a
while yeah whatever and there's simply
nothing threatening again striking
getting play King edge one he has no
ability to play a five okay he had
actually interesting he could also take
with the bishop he might play a five so
I go here the sea the sea seven point is
sighs this week anyway and I'm need I
need to make sure that he doesn't get
any any big counter play if I prevent
any kind of um yeah tricks whatever this
typical kind of nonsense that that they
drive then then I'm just winning Queen
be tuned they don't really get what is
doing Queen eh eh eh aight i just play
rugae one yeah now i get the iphone or
is this his first game or something no
he's got the super score here yep hard
to understand sometimes of what's
happening here okay
I'm on the f5 square and yeah if you
want let's check see 790 cannot protect
it anyway
I just want to get this I just want to
win the c7.r porn okay so it's not
hanging here but if i take here play b6
ok so let's just calculate this if i go
be 696 the roxy 7 and resins yeah and
exchanging the quinces also also over
okay you can take f3 this is of course
the IDM so should I just men just take
it mmm Queenie to maybe Queenie to talk
to secure to the cute so to secure the
position a bit
so now here this is even an improvement
so how to how to continue now can also
just move the night I mean use the night
somewhere
yeah okay this some calmly wasn't so
great should be too
ok what if he takes 83 years hanging so
I don't think I want that ok there is
some no problem of the army of course I
was just correcting this disability
because I don't don't accept a draw here
so f5 it's very hard to believe that you
could play that so I let's let's push
push the pawns now I don't see a big
town to play coming 94 to take this
check
you don't ask me how but he got some
constantly
and this book is not covered yeah if I
lose this this would be a really really
awful
yeah it's not it's not easy at all to
play this don't have don't have time
that's it's not exactly helping that's
that some person is using using so
cleaning cleaning the roof next next to
me I really ate it oh man yeah he could
have taken Ashley and I just Knight f3
unbelievable it's really unbelievable
I'm such an idiot losing against against
this unbelievable it was so winning for
blown and okay everything win so this is
this a kind of position where really
everything winds and you managed to not
do it is unbelievable they have class
adium of course of course it's plus 8
plus 10 b6 yeah okay of course yeah this
is this is already a bit tricky and this
is already be tricky unbelievable yeah
yeah I spent so much time before asking
myself from which loony bin this guy has
escaped and and the meantime I spoiled
it I mean it's it still plus 5 by my
comp standards but the night the nights
are our clothes and this is always
tricky down ig1 is winning again and
this is now losing
now g 1 is plus 5 again huh yeah what
can you do where did I spend so much
time you played rather quickly he was
ahead on time yeah here I spent some
time c7 is plus 10 oh great yeah I spy I
lost some time with with those bishop
moves I thought there must be something
to exchange Queens somehow there wasn't
and this was was annoying i mean ok + 8
m ok um next game